welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the one out of ten
looks wise and in this video we're
breaking down the matrix for
resurrections now normally when a film
drops like this i do a big trailer
breakdown but i thought i'd change
things up and do a video discussing way
more about the movie than what i
typically tend to touch upon that gives
context to this first look the trailer
was actually shown at cinemacon and i
was lucky enough to get a lot of info on
it sent in advance on not only the
teaser but also what's going to be
happening in the film so big big
breakdown and in this video we'll be
going over the story in general what
insiders have said about the film and
also some of the easter eggs and things
that you missed from the teaser what if
i told you that there will be heavy
spoilers as some of these things might
ruin a lot of the big reveals if you
don't want anything spoiled then i
recommend that you unplug but if you
stick around then it is your purpose to
subscribe without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's enter the matrix
okay so over the last couple of days
we've had a lot of teasers towards the
film though a blue and red pill video
dropped on tuesday that was announcing
when the trailer was coming if you
visited the website it was possible to
get two teasers that hindered towards
what's coming in the film these first
looks had yaya abdul mateen playing a
young version of morpheus and he gave a
similar speech to what he did in the
first matrix when he discussed reality
and how we must question everything
around us he brought up the time which
was 6 27 and this random number could
actually be a nod to luke 6 27 from the
bible if that's the case then it refers
to the passage about how you should turn
the other cheek and it is rumored that
the humans and machines are actually
working together in the film we do see
at one point morpheus touching a mirror
and this bends and twists much like the
mirror scene in the first film this is
later reflected hey and another part
when a gun comes out of it from the
other side making me think that mirrors
are indeed portals and jump points
within the matrix the phrase through the
looking glass was used heavily in the
first film and the idea of mirrors is
something that pops up throughout the
entire trailer the phrase through the
looking glass actually pulls from the
book alice in wonderland and this shows
up at one point when neo visits a
bookstore i think it's really
interesting how the steam and water
droplets on the mirror look like the
famous green coating that was everyone's
screensaver in 1999 and i believe that
this has been done on purpose to hint
towards their importance now a lot of
people are confused over the timeline
and how morpheus is younger when both
trinity and neo are actually the same
age take this with a big grain of salt
but according to rumors surrounding the
film the real morpheus died of old age
and when the matrix was rebooted a
bootleg copy was brought in similar to
the characters that we see in the film
he will be someone who questions his own
reality and he will have to come to
grips with being built into the
simulation in the real world nayobi is
apparently still alive and she will have
taken morpheus place as the leader of
humanity at one point in the film he
will fight neo in a dojo that is heavily
riffing upon the scene in the first film
however neo will be far more powerful
and brutal than what we saw him doing in
that movie i think it's super smart by
the creators to call back to moments
like this as they are of course iconic
and remind us exactly why we fell in
love with the franchise in the first
place now as for neo he will attend a
lot of therapy sessions throughout the
movie and we'll learn that he actually
erased his own memory but glimpses of
this will come to him through the form
of flashbacks he will have two looks in
the film namely his quote unquote john
wick one and also the completely shaven
one that pops up in the pods this would
have been the perfect time for me to
drop a manscaped ad that i was actually
gonna do this week but i messed up and
didn't get it done on time so i'm sorry
if you guys are watching this now i will
i will link my code in the description
below if you want to check it out as
there's some great discounts now moving
on neo has created a fake life for
himself that he sedates with blue pills
which of course calls back to the first
film as it was in that that we saw these
led someone away from escaping the
matrix according to the leaks neo is
actually a game developer that worked on
a trilogy of games for warner brothers
i'm not kidding they're meant to be
called the matrix now this is super
fourth wall breaking and it's a really
fun thing that i think will add so much
to the movie at one point in the trailer
we see him taking the blue pills and if
you look in the mirror you'll see a much
older reflection of him standing there
this makes me think that his age is
really gonna come into question here and
we'll learn that he's way older than he
appears in the first film switch was
actually gonna be a man in the real
world and a woman in the matrix and this
was going to show that you could really
appear in the simulation exactly how you
felt you looked potentially this old man
could be the way that the world and nioh
sees himself and when he breaks through
the simulation he gets to see his real
face i think by the looks of it that the
movie will be tackling mental health
themes and highlighting people who
question their reality whilst asking if
there's any legitimacy to it just when i
thought i'd finally settled on being
kevin's spoilers this movie is gonna
make me question if i actually exist and
if there's any point in doing youtube
anymore especially with the way i
pronounce matrix make me make rick now
true throughout we're going to watch him
attend a lot of therapy sessions with a
character played by neil patrick harris
this will be known as the analyst and
he's a super intelligent machine that is
responsible for bringing the humans and
the ai together neo will be called
anderson a call back to his name in the
first film and he'll also meet trinity
who is now going under the name tiffany
though they don't have breakfast at
tiffany's site the pair do come face to
face at a coffee shop we can see in the
trailer that the coffee shop is called
simulate and it also has the green color
that's associated with the matrix code
simulate becomes simulate if you remove
one t and coffee is of course something
that wakes you up when you're tired this
is perhaps hinting at how neo will wake
up or perhaps it's the big reach in the
video that you've been waiting for
they're struck with deja vu and this
makes them begin to remember their life
beforehand and deja vu was of course
caused by a glitch in the matrix now if
we look at the rumors reports and behind
the scenes info this coffee shop is
supposed to be the jumping off point for
a big action scene the analyst is
apparently studying neo and he's doing
this in order to see if trinity will
remember him as it's at this point that
he will become unstoppable when the pair
realize that they do know one another
this will send things spiraling out of
control and there'll be a massive action
and chase scene in which they start to
work together this will send them on a
quest to uncover the truth about what's
really going on and during this time
they'll come across a character called
bugs played by jessica henrik this movie
is meant to open with her being chased
by agents which of course riffs on the
first film and how that started up bugs
and morpheus will apparently work
together to resurrect neo so that he can
once more be the one i have no idea why
this needs to be done if the humans are
cool with the machines but obviously we
need some conflict in the film so my
guess is that there are some rebels
amongst the humans that want to rise up
now lastly the two big other characters
that are returning are apparently the
merovingian and agent smith the former
will be played by lambert wilson once
more but hugo weaving will not be
returning as the ladder this is people
speculating a lot over who could be
portraying the iconic villain and
judging by the trailer i actually think
that it's going to be jonathan groff you
might know the actor from mind hunter
and hamilton and he definitely has the
acting skills to pull off something like
smith there is a scene in which you can
catch the character with his mouth
sticking together i think it would be
great if this was carried out by neo
smith of course did the same thing to
neo in the first matrix film and it
would just be a nice little switcheroo
now there are theories going around that
neo is actually the creator of this
brand new world but he doesn't know that
he built it so it makes a lot of sense
that his subconsciousness would pull
things into it this would definitely
include smith who was of course a big
part of the character's life death
rebirth other death and now his
resurrection now some of the
miscellaneous easter eggs include what i
initially thought was the nebuchadnezzar
but shout out simon a birman on twitter
for sending me through that it's
actually the men
now this is named after the greek
goddess of memory which of course ties
into the overall theme of the film we
also know that pods will appear in the
film as well as several callbacks to
what's come before there are red and
blue pills and a fight scene in which i
believe that agent smith punches neo
really fast which is of course a call
back to their fight in the train station
from the first movie in addition to this
the analyst's room also has some easter
eggs including a black cat and a
butterfly which is of course a symbol of
rebirth we see that bugs also has a
white rabbit tattoo and this was of
course a big thing in the first film
that not only linked to alice in
wonderland but it also got neo to me
trinity there's also a moment where a
gun is held up and this looks very
similar to the dodge this moment however
on top of this the gun looks very
similar to agent smith's and though it's
very blurred that does look like
jonathan groff so yeah smith confirmed
you might also notice there is somewhat
of a green tint over the top of the
trailer and this of course reflects when
someone is in the matrix whereas in the
real world the the colors are more
natural or they're really blue sometimes
sometimes it's really blue now whether
this is true or not i have been told
that trinity and neo both rely on each
other in order to unlock their abilities
that's why the pair meeting is so
dangerous and it's also the reason that
neocon fly when we first see him there's
also a moment where we see code moving
down trinity's face and this makes me
think that they're activating and
somewhat unlocking both their powers
overall it makes a lot of sense looking
at this teaser and i like the idea of
them being somewhat helping the other to
grow now as for my thoughts on the first
look i tried to think about how i feel
about the trailer but it was only then
that i realized the truth that there is
no trailer now by that i mean there is a
trailer obviously and it's really good
in my opinion now a question you
probably have is did i enjoy the matrix
trilogy i'll answer your question by
saying that i was in high school when it
came out so yeah i think pretty much
every high schooler did including me i
loved the first film and though i didn't
initially like the second and third over
the years i have come to appreciate what
they were doing in terms of telling a
modern day jesus story they of course
have their faults but whatever they were
they weren't enough to put me off this
first trailer and i am really sold on
the film at this point i love that it's
reusing a lot of the previous
iconography and it looks like it's also
breaking the fourth wall to make us
question our own reality once more this
did a great job of getting me hyped up
for the film and december is going to be
an amazing month with both this and
spider-man no way home now until then
i'd love to hear your thoughts on the
teaser so make sure you comment below
and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy on the 30th of september and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the first look we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now say that to you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
emails to watch then make sure you check
out our break and have one if episode 5
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the whole thing from top to
bottom and it was a hell of a lot of fun
especially all the zombies so definitely
go watch it right after this if not then
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace